now well it's time to get into the
valentine's day spirit and love
obviously
is in the air and rocky diaz has got you
covered
this week yeah today she took a trip to
the twilight zone to show us
how we can celebrate with a sci-fi twist
if that's what you're into
yeah if you're into that kind of thing
obviously the kids are loving it this
you can have a perfect play date or
birthday party here but monster mini
golf is not just for the kids
no it's for adults too it's a perfect
date night because we're kicking off
valentine's week so this is the founder
of monster mini golf let's talk about
what people can do here for date night
yeah we're actually really talking let's
take a look we're actually a really cool
date night spot um we're 18 holes in
mini golf and it can kind of keep you
talking if you're really shy yeah if
you're really competitive it's even cool
for that
look at that yeah it's very visually
stimulating trivia on the golf course we
do contests and things like that we have
music on the golf course so we keep it
lots of fun that's awesome and i
understand you've had proposals here
you've had first dates
yeah yeah we do we have a lot of a lot
of first dates obviously
but we've and we've actually had people
come back from their first date and do
a proposal here as well and we've even
taken a step further than that
oh my god okay wait before you get to
the step further i feel like
you know in the spirit of valentine's
day it all starts with the right pickup
line right
yeah i guess and in sci-fi world you got
to have the right
pick up line with the sci-fi theme so
because i'm so smooth i've written a few
downs all right on my paper here
all right so i'm going to start i'm
going to start off okay you mind no go
ahead go ahead
christina you are out of this world
would you like to boldly go where no one
has gone before
okay and this one is from my editor
david this one's from my editor david
you're going to like this
you're like a phaser on stunning oh geez
are you flushing under that mask i think
she's blushing under that mask
so after the pickup line after the
sci-fi date night here
we get a sci-fi wedding right we do
sci-fi wedding chapel it's awesome
show us boy show us the way i think we
might have something cool going on
something cool like an actual wedding we
do oh gosh we have to be quiet obviously
what do i get you get pretty much
whatever you intergalactically want
we will do anything it's just a fun
really cool
sci-fi wedding chapel so sci-fi um
vip passes we've got custom cakes any
minister you could possibly want
wow yeah that's awesome and of course
you guys have some other
venues around town as well right that
have different themes we do we have a
kiss venue over at the rio and so we
have a rock and roll chapel there as
well love that
yes full-on rock and roll so we kind of
got both sides of the spectrum going on
you've got it covered for everyone
you've never done
monster mini golf so last question here
um what makes the perfect
vegas wedding imagination and love
that's great thank you christina oh
thank you for this fine establishment
i will should we do the should we do oh
okay
i'm not very good at this greetings
salutations